going back to paying rent there's this
thing called a key fee what was it like
not it's like it's key money right and
and I mean you can explain if you want
go ahead it's like what can I say it's
two months of rent some sometimes it's
so the amount is about two months of
rent that you pay to the rent owner to
say thank you for renting me your place
free I felt as you don't get me you
don't get it back at you you this money
is literally not a deposit you just pay
two months of rent just which you also
have to pay a deposit on top of the
deposit that you have to pay just it's
basically a dicksuck that's what it is
it's like thank you so much for letting
me stay in your what it is and then it
doesn't end there because you then have
to pay the rental the the agency that
got you the house you have to pay a
month's rent to them yeah yeah which is
just stupid because I think in every
other country they take their split from
the person renting the house right like
not from you because renting a house
shouldn't be you shouldn't have to pay
like six to eight months up front
that's ridiculous yeah and it's I think
it's the reason why a lot of homeless
people here also struggled to get houses
how the [ __ ] are you gonna get six
months worth of rent right and money are
you kidding me like this like you expect
when you when you look at the rent you
expect like okay this is how much I'm
gonna pay for the first iPad was it
thank you yeah maybe like a month or two
yeah yeah no it's like double or triple
Jesus Christ ridiculous yeah stupid